[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo che
cazzo sto facendo pero gasato scusate mi
succede a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vigente oggi siamo
su tron face quest 13 allora e laverty
ragazzi rimasti al 6
anch'io i problemi ragazzi che dopo il 6
non hanno fatto il set hanno fatto il 13
quindi ragazzi non sapevano contare fino
a 7 oppure hanno le idee un po confuse
però vabbè chissà perché poi ti può più
13 tra tutte le cose è morto
beh bisogna sempre centrare il buco in
qualche modo ragazzi da morale questa
che ragazzi prima di cominciare vi
spiego un attimo di alcol è la storia
perfetto la cervicale giornale cioè un
cespuglio di bamba spunta un maniaco
certo e tenta di accoltellarlo mi sembra
ovvio è certo il bello è che se si salta
la presentazione c'è la faccina triste
ciò che non la puoi saltare che sono si
offende va bene zio nella saltiamo
andiamo avanti si è tranquillo era un
pennarello non incolte ali ha scritto 13
sulla fronte e lui è rimasto triste
andiamo avanti ragazzi ma lasciamo a
fare qualcosa con la carta scoppiettante
vi ho ragazzi sta roba qua la d'oro cioè
ogni volta che nella realtà la schiaccia
e un orgasmo ragazzi mi sento proprio
libero è una cosa bellissima
sì sì sì se però non è la stessa cosa
non dagli stessi orgasmiche né da nella
vita reale però ma no ma doha dove è
quella sensazione sotto le dita che ti
fa godere quando scoppiano che cosa
brutta ma ci sia la categoria su youporn
di dean di scoppieto di di bolsena roba
orgasmica ragazzi non dà la stessa
sensazione propri cari sto mouse non è
orgasmico ma che cosa devo fare tra
l'altro è gà lupica qualcosa che non è
quello come al solito antonsson tutti
così tra il fisco è strega deve essere
un maniaco che si stava masturbando
sulle bolle perché il quando scoppiano
un godimento
vabbè ragazzi non perdere sto livello
che bello ma è la mega evoluzione di una
patata oppure uno struzzo con delle
gambe brutte fatemi capire
va beh devo cliccare il tizio si no sì
certo è ovvio ragazzi mi sembra giusto
hai presente la cocaina che prendi prima
di creare questi giochi e complementi
nella parte che non è una buona marchena
rabanne indecente e continua a urlare
con un idiota conficca la testa nella
sabbia e io perdo ma che cazzo di
livello dovrebbe mai essere date voglio
delle sfighe dichiarano digno ragazzi
qualcuno chiami il barcellona che si sta
perdendo un fenomeno ma che i problemi
erano reagan
cos'è da è una roba cosa stai fatta
ragazzi poi gli effetti sonori che sono
un orgasmo per l'udito è pazzesco devo è
morto per chi sta anche bene in realtà
non ero dispiaciuto guardati fare morire
un paio di volte di più qualcuno ha un
trapano che cazzo ci cos'è successo un
trapano certo ma b perché giustamente il
buco ed è lei delle dimensioni del
trapano ma mi sembra giusto bravo
complimenti ragazzi sta migliorando di
livelli livello sono contentissimo
credete di fare qualche bello che silvio
c'è una cipolla al posto della testa
fammi capire devo scassinare che sta
banca certo come cazzo fatto così due ok
e facci esca siano una banca pensavo
fosse più difficile o file in coma o
fallito ma cosa ma sei scemo
ho vinto sei un deficiente lurida
cipolla di merda fatti grigliare è una
roba che so fare
spariscono devo farlo entrare il catcher
rimasta la candela niente lui è contento
anche per la candela ragazzi perché i
ragazzi chi trova una candela trova un
tesoro e questa è una cosa che risaputi
che invece vide a candela fammi capire
eri contento uguale adesso no perché non
c'è ecco infatti adesso sei triste ma
che cazzo se ne faceva della kander no
vi prego no chi cazzo è ed uscirà amico
mio ci canti una canzone fink in out
loud cantiamo all'alfa così when you lie
sound and music before ben ha quasi più
a fabio fei
[Musica]
poesia poesia la ed bravo bravo cazzo
che chi sei tu cugino di campagna
ragazzi per me è sì anche per la vecchia
quante cantare con il cile hanno ragazzi
cosa devo fare qua la s lo fa le
accadere in testa no e ora che cazzo
devo fare seriamente lega ma che così
qual è il problema di st vecchia il
cappello ma ovvio adesso scanso alle
monete [ __ ] vedi che niente lui e
continua a lamentarsi allora prendiamo
questo cappello e qua eh vabbè
aristotele discepolo di platone era
considerata una delle menti più
prolifiche intelligenti d'avanguardia
del mondo antico occidentale questo per
la vastità della sua conoscenza è stato
stimato per secoli come l'emblema
dell'uomo sapiente questo perché fu
anche precursore di scoperte e stiamo
parlando ragazzi nell'anno 300 avanti fa
vj quindi sono anni secoli secoli fa
praticamente sono passati secoli
l'umanità si è evoluta in una maniera
incredibile area siamo nel 2015 ragazzi
e nel 2015 abbiamo questa roba umanità
che cazzo ti è successo sento di aver
bisogno di un abbraccio ragazzi
credetemi e andiamo avanti prima che
cos'è lo scoppiare i palloncini mo perlo
perché mi sembra troppo facile infatti
guarda non avrei mai detto credo in
scolta zio della maestra tu per caso non
perché ti vedo bello informa ance la
leva come si certo
quale dovrebbe essere il senso di sta
col potere premuto perfetto l'importante
è che io stanotte non dormo cosa
dovrebbe essere sempre così ma ciao zio
[Musica]
ragazzi qualcuno mi deve spiegare il
senso di questo vi prego io ho paura è
la stessa identica reazione che ha avuto
mia madre la prima volta che ha visto il
disordine di casa mia
cazzo uguale ciao mamma che facciamo
anti oakley cosi cosi finche non muore
qualcuno ha un senso questo gioco
qualcuno mi dia una botta in testa e via
si spaventa in un modo bellissimo c'è
guardate io non ho parole lega sono
estasiato picazio cosa cazzo devo fare
cosa fa a caso ha deciso lui ha deciso
ragazzi ha deciso di muoversi a caso
così
vabbè ogni tanto si muovono non se ne sa
che che cazzo cliccato ma ok va bene
regali importanti e buttare sta roba
perfetto sì certo
ovviamente ragazzi non è né non è una
cosa strana è normale sono i videogiochi
del 2015 non pensate male c'è una rana
alquanto [ __ ] è un tipo che credo che
sia più figo della rana
sì ma stai calmo zio credimi fratello
che non è niente di male solo una rana è
solo una [ __ ] rana posso questo
ragazzi si chiama stupro è una roba
stranissima a parte il fatto che la rana
deve stuprare sto tizio ok era più
semplice di quanto pensassi va bene così
ascolta zio ma perché sei un culo al
posto del naso
no no no in tacco 14 scusa mi sono
confuso tipo che so fare e lanciarli a
moneta e si è [ __ ] di soldi e
perfette qual è il bronx a devo fare le
cose
il ventilatore attiva perfetto e adesso
adesso abbiamo più freddo perché fa un
caldo bass chiama donna tu che cazzo ci
fai con la felpa nation 30 gradi
all'ombra ascolta zio edy lancio lar
ragazzi avete i premi nobel che vi
avanzano perché io saprei a chi darli
non so se avete presente ok più che
andare avanti non so che cazzo fare
perché mi deprimo come pochi questo
pesca perché c'è un granchio che è
bellissimo yahoo ha un reale o mi solo
ed eventi che anche istruttivo
mi sono sempre chiesto che a cazzo
diverso faccia il granchio e adesso la
risposta
ciao ciao anche a te zio hashtag ciao
ragazzi io non so che cazzo fare in
questo livello ma nel dubbio geox
trofica ci sono dei pesci che non vedo
ovviamente
a questo si sa non sei educato zio
saluta dovrebbe mai essere questa cosa
ovviamente possa anche l'altro pesce no
perché sarebbe stata epica la sen
va beh l'importante è esserne convinti
ragazzi l'importante è quello di oh che
bel organi tu mi sono innamorato di
questo pesce bellissimo si chiamerà gil
ciao gil come stai ma sentite ragazzi
adottati da mangiare a quel problema e
questo sì però siete stronzi lasciate un
po ci riguarda non gli arriva niente agi
bastardi il pesce mio e gil fatevi i
cazzi vostri
niente si mangiano tutto prima che gli
arrivi stronzi di merda per dargli da
mangiare
no no
ha sentito lui e gil non debito carino e
gil se due tocchi da marzo la famiglia è
una roba che non ho capito che fai visto
livello a partire da mangiare a si era
più semplice di quanto pensassi perfetto
e mo che se gli hot rogati e lo sapevo
che sei proprio tu sei così bella non ti
voglio più guarda poi anche morire
adesso parti ha fatto eco lo so traccia
un culo al posto del mento per ok questo
fare qua intimidiamo gli altri pesci
ovviamente prossimo livello ragazzi
ancora non ho capito se questo gioco ha
un senso comunque questo che dorme tra
paghiamoli ovviamente il muro flag è
triste e piange certa ovviamente non
riesce a dormire una cosa fa piange ma
mi sembra ovvio anche io piango la notte
zio ma perché perché in questo martella
al muro giustamente zio questo mi piange
come se non ci fosse un domani ma perché
ma basta piangere e allora addio i
problemi si risolvono così by nell'altra
stanza e prendi a schiaffi il tizio è
l'unica è l'unica cazzo di maniera ok ho
trovato il modo per ha proposto
schiacciando è morto minchia mi dispiace
è non vedo guarda non era mia intenzione
con tutto l'amore che ho per te figure
cos'è sta roba mia di 13 f è un 13
questo non c'è il 13 perfetto 13 f l 1 3
e che cazzo me ne faccio della f 14 12 a
caso premendo a chiasso regalo un solo
che sto andando ma ok air triste e vabbè
mischia guarda passare la vita
nell'ascensore fare cantù a 2 mila clic
2004 antichi che cazzo combina il corso
cliccato non ho visto cosa ho cliccato
va bene così non importa come contento
ai sfasato un ascensore sei contento 13
ok ho fatta certo completato che ho 2010
click meraviglioso ragazzi c'è un motivo
secondo me se si erano formati al 6 di
trofei space forse perché hanno fatto il
7 8 9 10 11 e 12 ma facevano
esageratamente cagare non che questo sia
diverso per ok comunque ragazzi concluso
che l'episodio spero che vi sia piaciuto
è stato strano ti piaciuto gatto a gatto
è piaciuto ebbe l'importante è che il
gatto sia contento poi sono cazzi tuoi
quindi ragazzi servito è piaciuto a sé
con certamente mi piace ai cavalieri
facebook e con i video tratta
descrizione sensori si discute cv davano
passioni belle ragazze